[Music]
it's Michelle from Lab muffin beauty
science skincare nerd and chemistry PhD
if you've been following me for a while
you know I love talking about
ingredients and science and a lot of you
guys have been asking me to talk about
silicones in particular so I'm really
happy that grant industries asked me to
do a sponsored video all about silicones
grant industries is an ingredient
manufacturer who make a bunch of
cosmetic ingredients including gran
active rational physical sunscreens and
of course silicones in this video I'm
going to be talking about what silicones
are what they do and we're going to bust
some myths about silicones that you've
probably seen around the internet if you
like this sort of video give it a thumbs
up subscribe to my channel and make sure
you click the notification bell so you
don't miss any videos first up what is
the silicone silicones are organo cilok
scenes which contain alternating silicon
oxygen silicon bonded to carbon atoms
silicones originally come from sand
which is silicon dioxide there are a few
different types of silicones which have
different properties and uses to spot a
silicon in your product look for names
that end in cone Canole or siloxane
ingredients that ends in silane usually
aren't silicones because they don't have
enough silicon and they have slightly
different properties in the realm of
silicones there are small silicones
which tend to be very liquid and they're
often volatile which means they
evaporate and they don't stay on your
hair or skin this category includes
phenol traumatic own which is really
small and cyclo penta siloxane which is
a small volatile cyclic silicone there
are also silicone polymers which are
long-chain molecules made up of
repeating siloxane units these can be
liquid or solid for example dimethicone
proper name poly dimethyl siloxane and
poly methyl Sol sasquatch seen you can
also get functionalized silicones like a
madhumitha cone and dimethicone all
which have a few other atoms on their
structures which give them special
properties on top of what regular
silicones do
[Music]
silicones are everywhere in beauty
products they've been used and
researched since the 1950s there's a
good reason silicones are so popular
they have some really cool properties
that other ingredients just don't have a
lot of this comes from the fact that
silicones are really unreactive
ingredients with a really smooth Glide
they're also cruelty free and vegan in
skincare silicones are hypoallergenic
non-irritating and non-comedogenic
they're good moisturizers and they help
product spread on your skin they can
actually enhance the penetration of
active ingredients and protect them from
degrading before you apply them
waterproofing silicones can be used in
sunscreens to help them stay on while
you swim and they can also be used to
coat mineral sunscreen particles to stop
them from clumping and to reduce the
free radicals that form when they get
exposed to sunlight you can also use
silicones to protect your skin from wind
and chafing in makeup silicones are
great because they glide onto your skin
and that means that your makeup blends
in much more easily in makeup primers
they can also fill in lines and pores
making your skin look plumper and less
wrinkly and it gives you a smooth canvas
for the rest of your makeup
there are also silicones that prolong
the wear time of makeup which means that
it's really good for keeping foundations
or lipsticks stuck to your skin while
still being flexible enough that it
won't crack silicones can also have a
matte look that can blow a light and
this makes your skin look more
airbrushed when they're in hair care
products silico smooth out hair detangle
it and make it shinier plus they protect
your hair from heat styling and humidity
they can also help hair dye stay on for
longer so if silicones are so great why
are there so many myths about them like
with a lot of other beauty topics online
you'll see myths that have no basis in
reality and you have myths that start
with a grain of truth and quickly mutate
into something else entirely silicones
are synthetic and not natural this is
true and coupled with the fact that
they're so popular I think this is the
main reason there's so many myths about
silicones I've covered the topic of
synthetic and natural in an earlier
video us humans have a bias towards
thinking that natural is better safer
more environmentally friendly and etc
but this just isn't true natural does
not mean safer synthetic does not mean
more dangerous for you or the
environment the most toxic
in the world are natural in beauty
products natural plant extracts are some
of the ingredients that cause the most
irritation and allergic reactions when
we use natural products sometimes it's
incredibly destructive to the
environment things like palm oil
sandalwood ivory and shark's fin you can
check out my video on natural versus
synthetic if you want more details so
the word natural doesn't mean very much
so let's ignore the natural part and
we'll focus on the real issues instead
this is the perception that natural
things are safer for your body in terms
of health and better for the environment
and therefore the myths that silicones
are not good for your health and not
good for the environment silicones are
bad for sensitive skin this isn't true
and in fact it's the opposite silicones
are frequently used in medicine because
they're so hypoallergenic and
dimethicone is actually an FDA approved
skin protectant most people can put
undiluted dimethicone on their skin with
no issues silicones are toxic to human
health this is another one of those
myths that grew from the whole natural
is better notion silicones are actually
really safe
they haven't been linked to cancer or
hormone disruption or any other
long-term health effects and regulatory
authorities around the world have said
that they're not a risk to humans
silicones are used in lots of medicated
treatments like ointment sand creams and
even inside the body of medical devices
like pacemakers and hydrocephalic shunts
in the brain silicones are also found in
anti farting oral medication where it
breaks up gas bubbles silicones
suffocate your skin and cause acne a lot
of the logic for why silicones are bad
comes from the idea that they form a
solid occlusive film on your skin for
example you'll often see that silicones
are described like a layer of rubber or
that they trap dirt and germs in your
pores like plastic wrap supposedly this
film interferes with your skin's natural
processes so it kind of slowly ate sweat
regulate its temperature or produce
cells properly but this isn't the case
and it's hard to work out where these
myths come from other than just
speculation there's zero research that
shows any of this silicones actually
form a breathable layer on your skin
it's permeable to oxygen and water vapor
and this is actually a problem when
silicone rubber is used in equipment it
can actually form a gas tight seal
oxygen and water molecules can actually
wiggle out in between the flexible
last name chains in the silicon film
silicones also aren't very comedogenic
according to standard tests dimethicone
has a rating of one cyclomethicone has a
rating of zero any ingredient can clog
your pores and silicones are the same as
any other ingredient in this regard you
can find out more about commented inner
city ratings in my video on that if
you've used some products in the past
and you've concluded that silicones are
problematic for you keep this in mind
lots of people will get breakouts from
products and look for ingredients that
are common in their ingredient lists and
if they see dimethicone are other
silicones they might blame that but
silicones are incredibly common and
there's some of the most common
ingredients after water and since so
many products have silicones somewhere
around half of all skincare products
have them the chance of seeing them as
ingredients and products that break you
out is super high even if they're not
actually the cause there's also a
perception that because silicones are
used for long wear products they're hard
to remove from your skin at the end of
the day and they might build up over
time on your skin but it's really hard
to make anything occlusive that stays on
forever because you shared one layer of
skin cells a day a buildup of silicone
or anything else on your skin just
doesn't happen silicones just make your
skin look nice but they don't actually
do anything or they make your skin worse
this myth is mostly talking about
dimethicone and skincare and there's a
similar myth for petrolatum or petroleum
jelly
it's that it Falls an impenetrable
occlusive film on your skin that dries
out your skin and makes it dehydrated
but apart from the fact that water can
actually pass through silicone films
there are some studies that also showed
that silicones can improve your skin in
one study Troopa so silicone in a cream
led to greater skin hydration and lower
transit pijama water loss then cream
alone another study found that trans
leopard roma water loss wasn't affected
which means it wasn't occlusive and it
didn't moss rise so it really depends on
the formulation also keep in mind that
dimethicone is an FDA Lister skin
protectant actives can't get through
silicones silicones aren't very
occlusive and the film that they form
breaks down over time silicones are
actually used to deliver active
ingredients and pharmaceuticals and
petroleum jelly which is much more
occlusive is used for this as well so
yes active ingredients can get through
silicone films and it won't build up on
your skin
even though within your skincare routine
it might make more sense to layer it
over other ingredients if you want more
immediate effects silicones do nothing
for your hair except coat it and make it
look shiny it's true that silicones form
a shiny coating on your hair but this is
a good thing
hiding damage is actually good hair is
pretty fragile and if your hair is
damaged it tends to snag more which just
leads to more damage smoothing out your
hair is good it stops cuticle scales
from snapping off which is what happens
when you feel friction when you comb
your hair and it can also make your hair
stronger and more resistant to breakage
silicone also protect your hair from
heat when you dry your curl or
straighten it so there greater
protecting your hair from damage which
is definitely doing something for your
hair there is one potential issue here
though
hairdressers tend to hate silicones
because they stay in your hair and it
stops treatments from getting through to
your hands
so coloring and perming might not turn
out as predicted so the solution to this
is pretty easy
just use a clarifying treatment before
you go to the hairdresser and stop using
silicones for a few days before you go
silicones down your hair and weigh it
down this can be the case for some
people with particular silicones
different people have different hair
needs not all silicones are the same and
the same concept applies to other hair
ingredients too like oils and fatty
alcohols for example before I bleach my
hair I found that dimethicone was
fantastic for my hair but after
bleaching sometimes it can feel a bit
heavy but Aimie dimethicone
is amazing amer dimethicone is
especially functional as silicone that
selectively biased a damaged hair it
avoids building up and it lasts through
a few washes it wasn't heavy enough for
my hair before I dyed it but now it's
perfect for targeting damaged silicones
are non biodegradable and toxic for the
environment it's technically true that
silicones aren't really biodegradable
but it's important to note that this
doesn't necessarily mean that it's bad
biodegradable means that it can be
broken down by living things like
bacteria but non biodegradable doesn't
mean that something is bad for example
glass is non biodegradable but it's
inert and non-toxic and so therefore
it's not a big issue silicones on the
other hand aren't biodegradable but they
do degrade in the environment and they
turn back into silica which is sand
carbon dioxide and water
for example dimethicone is
on biodegradable but it's mostly removed
when wastewater is treated it degrades
in contact with clays it's not water
soluble so it probably ends up in the
clays as well so it does degrade it's
just not biodegradable a lot of
silicones also evaporate into the air
and they degrade there when they meet UV
and sunlight and oxygen in the air for
most cyclic silicones used in beauty
products half will break down in two
weeks in soil and sediment they break
down in less than two years this is
relatively persistent from an
environmental chemistry standpoint but
it's actually really quick compared to
the things that we think of as known by
degradable like plastics which take
thousands of years to break down it's
also worth noting that the
concentrations of silicones around the
world in the environment are really low
even though we've been using them for a
long time and this suggests that they're
not really building up in the
environment the other issue is
environmental toxicity so other
silicones doing anything while they hang
around for up to two years most
authorities around the world think that
silicones are a little concern because
there are such low concentrations in the
environment and they're not very soluble
in water the only region which has
limits on silicones at the moment is the
EU which Lumis d4 and d5 this is because
Europe uses the precautionary principle
in their environmental regulation which
means that they don't really look at the
environmental evidence we're making
safety assessments they only look at
laboratory studies so at the moment with
what we know it doesn't look like
silicones are likely to be an
environmental problem although of course
if new evidence comes up we'll need to
revisit this I hope you like this video
if you did give it a thumbs up and you
can also subscribe to my channel for
more you can also follow me on instagram
at lab muffin beauty sighs and check out
my blog for more nerding out see you
next time